[音楽]
dare
[拍手]
みなさんこんにちは
今回のデックスって
お題があり9ティックっていうことで私が考えたものは想像力ひらがなで想像力と書き
ました
ひさしの言い方はイェイ
推測できると思いますがこの想像力は2つの
言葉に対応しています一つはイマジネーションの想像力一つは
クリエーションの想像力です
これは今日お話しする私が運営するスノーとカフェの大切なテーマでもあります
いつものカフェという珍しい名前は同じく弊社が上している
リサイクルブティック相撲ドールっと言う名前を訳したものです
このつ no ドールの菅生
っていうところをつけて
どのようになりましたこれはいつからかお客様が勝手に楽して気軽にお話してくれたん
ですが
そう名前を使って
2006年に相撲ドカフェをオープンしました
そのとか風はもちろんカフェです
普通にコーヒー持っていますただ
カフェだけではありません
スノドカフェをいつもご聞かれるんですがそのときに表す言葉をちょっといつも悩んで
しまう
まあ一言で今説明すると
なんていうか
まあ今ならこう言います
まあ来るべき市民社会のための実験室
ちょっとお湯さでねー
どういうことかと言えばまあこれからやってくるであろう
市民社会4担う人を育てるような場所を作りたいと考えているからです
これからは個人レベルで乳とか
皇居ということを
求められていくこれまで以上に求められていくと推測できます
また多様な考え方が複雑に絡み合う
まあ世の中になっていくと思うのでまあそうした時にそういった状況に柔軟に対応
できる
思考力を身につけていく必要があるのではないか
という問題からです
そうした考えのもとに取り組んでいるのが
まあ対話の場づくりということですねまあその必要性や重要性はまあ昨今すごく
取り上げられています
そこでまあ私は思うカフェという場にはそれを担う能力があるのではないかという考え
で
その対話の場食い物に取り組んでいます
かれこれオープンして10年がたちますが今はこの清水にある
オルタナティブスペースののカフェ
出現町にあるスタートカフェ地検長佐藤最近
市民文化会館にもお店を出させていただいています
今回登壇するということで改めて自分
10年やってきたイベントの数を数えてみました
2006年からですね並走するとまぁ数えとかってで700回以上あります
まあこれは一致切っ会まあ20人が例えば
参加するとすると
だいたい1万4000人ぐらいの人が参加したということになります
この1万4000人は多分10年かかって一番4前にだから決して多くはないと思い
ます
ただ自分たちのイベントは性格を考えると結構
検討しているのではないかというまあ自負もあります
それはなぜかというと
二枚そのドカフェのイベントはまあただのお客様でいられる
ばかりではないということです
積極的に効果変わっていくような能動的な姿勢というものをこちらからもまあ求めて
いうかあんまーそういったあードルのある高さというものがありますのでまぁその中で
にょ人が変わってくれたっっていうことは大変
まあ満足しているっていうことです
まあこれだけの数があるといわゆるカルチャーセンターやカルチャースクール
のようなものに
感じられるかもしれませんしかしそのとカフェをそのように言った方は
ぱほぼいません
まあそれはなぜかというと
先ほど
能動的な姿勢を止めると言いましたが
まあの共に学ぶというコンセプトを掲げているからだと思っています
つまり
先生と生徒が一方的な指導によって
関係を持つと言うだけではなくっていうことですね
技術を教えるだけではなくてスノドカフェで最も
まあ大事にしていること
それは他者の考えから学ぶということです
その時に講師先生は先生というより
まあしりデーターだったりキュレーターのような存在と言っていいと思います
こういったちょっと紹介せますが古典戯曲牢屋向かいとか
分者を講座とか6初回とかいわゆるまあ
哲学カフェとか文系の my 弁当をたくさん
主に行っています
妻壁をこのような場所と
太平台湾の場所というのは本セプト的には別に何も新しいことではありません
それなりに歴史を持っていてまあそのとか変もそれを生みならたりしています
それはどんなことかというとヨーロッパのカフェ文化ですね
でも近代ヨーロッパが市民社会をつくるに形成していくにあたって
例えばイギリスのコーヒーハウスああ
あるいはパリのカフェというものが市民社会並走する上で重要な場所だったと言われて
います
パソ子は自由に参加できてこれからの社会を考える市民の対話の場だったわけですね
プライベートとパブリックが混ざり合うような場所
そういった場所だったと思います
ますの壁が目指しているのはまあそういった場所ですね
まあただ私たちはそれほど
対話を得意としているわけではないと思います
例えば意見の違うことを意見を違うとして受け入れるっていうことはけっこう難しい
ことです
まあ表ではなくて避難になってしまうということはまあ誰しもごう3の覚えのあること
ではないかなと思います
いきなり難しい社会問題を
慣れていない対話によって知らない人間同士と同じテーブルで
対話をするっていうことは実際にはあまり現実的ではないと思います
ではどうやって総体腕力を鍛えていくか
そこで僕的に思うのはパートの出番がやってくるということです
答えのないアートは
藤塚っしょいねとても適しています
まあ否定されることがないということがあります
またパートは個人の近くから生まれてくるのでその違いを認め合う
ということについても深く考えさせてくれるからです
ってそもそもまあ私がこういった場をつくろうと思ったのはあっ
頭は逆でアートが最初だったわけですよね
最初にその台湾重要性に気が付いたのもアートに余ったからでした
パートを楽しんでまぁあと学んでいくうちに家
対話が生まれ自分自身の考え方に対応性が出てきた
っていうことをまあ自覚するようになったからです
そういったアートが身近にあれば対話の機会が増えて
つなどカフェの学びの場づくりのアプローチ
っていうのはまあパート
あとから始まるっていうことになっていきました
まあ思考実験としてマートを経験したり様々なタイプのハートを
触れることによって考え方にも幅が広がる
そのためにはまずアート買いが活発になってほしい
と思っています
そのためにパスノートカフェができることはやっていこうと
まあ例えばアーティストの発表機会提供するだとか
鑑賞者ととでありのままを作っていけ
そういったことも数カフェの仕事として行なっています
こうした活動によってそのドカフェを
コミュニティとみなすことができると思いますが私としてはプラットフォームという形
をとっていきたいと思っています
これが何が違うかというとマークも見えていっていうのはまあ何だのとかでもまあ精神
するのはコミュニティみたいな形をつくって政治にするのがまあ確かに効率が良いと
思いますカーだあにょまぁちょっとにょ時間を経過することによっ
ダンタンそのコミュニティが閉じていってしまうということが挙げられると思います
ブーブの人柄か安易に杭なあっていうあの雰囲気を感じるって言う言葉あっあった
ブーブーのせいだなぁありまーすでそういった性質もうちょっとこう
避けるために自分が考えていることを
まぁそういうか松本カフェがプラットフォームになってそういったコミュニティ同士が
交わり息の中の人たちがそのカフェで出会い交流をしていく
まあそういったフラット for 文
を目指しています
そのためには何が一番重要かというと
まあオープンであることですね open です
それが一番大事だと思っていますスマートカフェがまあ1ても私がこう
気を使っていることは常にそこは開かれた場所だっていうことです
そして来るべき市民社会の
準備としてまー銃弾が想像力を
育まれるような場所を作っていきたいと思って考えております
最近ジャバカフェの外などでもそういう間作りの仕事をするようになりました
これは8今年の5月目
線プジョー公営の中で
行われたフェスティバルガーデンっていうのを企画したりしております
他社の想像力を受け入れることは
可用性の第一歩です
私がアートに見せられるのはそういった能力がアートにはあるからです
パソの可能性を追求する
実験しっ
港そのアートをシェアする場所
それがわたしにとってのます喉壁ということです
最後になりますが
想像力に関する好きな言葉でこのスピーチを締めさせていただきたいと思います
ピーリスの小説家の言葉です
まあ生真面目パワー
ピザファイナルナチュラルいそう left for ガス
まあ
想像力とは地球に残された最後の天然資源だみたいな言葉と
思います
もし
想像力が資源だと見なされ
飛んだとしたら
最低でも都合のいい事が一つ挙げます
それはまあ奪い合うことのない石ゲーということです
手綱ラバー
それは各自が持ち得てしかも
無尽蔵だからです
この想像力を高めるために何ができるのか
小さなスゴカフェのような小さな学びの場
ポーネットワークできないだろう
より多くの人がダイナミックに学び合え
来るべき市民社会へ準備
そんな環境づくりに
これからも取り組んでいきたいと思っています
以上ご静聴ありがとうございましたはぁ